我现在跟另一半现在是说是在第二次的申请离婚的冷静期，
然后他这边又反悔了嘛，
我跟他是相亲认识的，
然后现在的话是第三年结婚，
第三年有一个小孩现在2岁，
第二年的时候就是有发现他聊在微信上去跟别人聊天这种，
然后吵过，
后来就是有一次动手了，
动手之后呢，
我这边是报警了，
报警之后就是去申请了第一次那个分手，
当时调解之后说是会影响小孩，
以后就是嗯，
各方面吧，
然后我后来相当于是调解了，
调解之后就是两边的家长也劝了，
考虑到小孩子就是我们也算是和好了吧，
和好了一段时间，
就是因为那个他开店的事情，
当时在银行做了一笔贷款，
拉着我去签了字，
然后作为负债人当时不知道，
然后现在的话是知道这个东西是其实作为担保人签的字，
经过这个事情之后，
后面有一段时间因为带小孩的问题，
因为我这边结婚之后是全职带小孩，
呃，
带到2岁不到一岁半左右就考虑想给他妈妈带，
然后他妈爸妈这边考虑的是说他自己就是里经上了十几年的班，
就是想着说让我自己再带一段时间嘛，
然后那段时间可能因为我们两个本身也处于矛盾期，
然后跟他父母又吵了一架，
吵了一架之后呢，
他爸妈就搬出去了，
搬出去之后大概2。
3个月吧，
然后又搬回来了，
同意帮我带小孩了，
然后回来之后就是我这边就找工作上班了，
目前第二次的亲情，
第二次分手的原因就是我们虽然说从他爸妈搬回来帮我带小孩之后吧，
但是我这边是不太，
就是跟他一直也是属于分房，
然后消费也属于就是我上班挣钱之后就是各花各的，
他可能接受不了，
这个之后就是有名无实嘛，
这个东西我本身也是为了考虑孩子，
就是你给他一个完整的家吧，
而且而虑且我当时没有工作，
我就想着说就过这种有名无实的生活，
就对他好，
对我也好，
我也不太想去干涉他其他的太多的东西，
也算是经历过这些东西之后才才看开吧，
我知道他爸妈应该跟他商量了一些什么事情，
然后他这边反悔之后，
意思就是说可以保持现在的状态继续过下去，
但是我这边其实在纠结的是我现在有稳定的工作，
工资的话，
我觉得负担我一个小孩的话应该是OK的，
然后抚养权的问题，
刚开始协际上当是给我，
后来他这边反悔之后说可能也不太愿意，
然后我这边是在纠结，
一个是就是他反悔之后，
我要不要就目前的状态继续跟他保持下去，
还有一个就是我考虑要不要再就是起诉，
然后就去走那个程序上的分手，
小女孩现在是多大来着。
在两岁四个月，
他们那家人带的比较多一点是吗？
今年3月初给他带的，
今年3月初3月初是给婆婆带的是吗？
对对，
你的爸爸妈妈是干什么工作的，
就是也是在这边就附近买，
大概也就几十公里，
承包了一个葡萄园嘛，
就假设跟他分开了之后，
你带着女儿干过的话，
那谁来帮你呢？
考虑的是说我这边有那种托儿所，
然后可以缓冲一段时间，
因为到明年的下半年，
他这边就可以上幼儿园了，
那你自己的工作是能够兼顾带他，
然后上班预影下吗？
对，
基本上的话，
我因为是八小时双休嘛，
其实放摊所以几个小时，
然后基本上周六周末双休，
我自己可以带，
然后早晚的话，
我觉得应该是没有问题的，
两家人完全帮不上忙嘛，
就是说如果说时间上帮不上忙，
钱上能帮上忙吗？
我的原生家庭就是这边是靠不住的，
还有一个就是我第二次申请离婚之前，
就是把我原生家庭的所有亲属全部拉黑了，
就是因为这个事情涉及到就是我这边已经坚持离婚的两个原因，
其中一个就是他这边，
男方这边的家庭，
就是但凡是有一点点小问题也好，
然后就喜欢去找我爸妈，
找我家里的人去说我的问题，
让他们来劝我，
就让我改一改啊什么的。
还有一次就是我不能接受的是第一次申请离婚之后，
他父母，
他的爸爸去打电话给我妈妈说，
说我精神有问题，
但孩子带的精神有问题，
在他们男方家庭亲戚圈也说了，
然后又去找到我爸妈说了这件事情，
你现在手上有存款吗？
差不多10个左右，
我跟你年收入在8万左右嘛，
如果你跟他协议分开的话，
从这段婚姻出来，
你身上要背债务吗？
只有一个，
我刚刚跟您说的那个，
就是作为担保人签字的那个抵押贷，
但是他是以房子来进行抵押的，
然后我咨询过其他的一些，
就是专业的这方面的人，
他是说因为他有一个房子在这里，
正常来说的话就是问题不会不会太大，
而且他自己愿意去单独承担这个债务，
就不会牵扯到我，
这是他自己说的这方面，
那你带着孩子过是要租房子吗？
考虑是这样，
还有一个打算的话，
可能就是要么租房子，
要么就是自己在自己按揭一个公寓之类的，
那你呃，
跟他分开的时候会分到一些钱吗？
就是你手上这10万的存款会倒分给他5万吗？
还是说你还能从他那里再分一部分，
不会不会因为我们当时协议离婚，
就第二次分手，
第二次分手的时候我约定的是说我只要抚养钱，
然后他开了一个店铺，
还有一辆车。
也是贷款买的，
然后目前这个房子它属于婚前首付，
然后可能婚前首付比较多，
大概一大半吧，
然后现在其实婚后还贷的部分比较少，
然后我当时跟他约定的是说我只要抚养权嘛，
其他的我都不要姐妹，
我觉得你现在这个状态，
你一个人带着孩子的话，
你的抵御风险的能力几乎为零，
说句难听点的话，
你也不敢定孩子也不敢定是吧，
你一边要工作，
一边要照顾孩子，
但凡是你工作中遇到什么压力了，
工作中遇到什么加班了，
或者你这头感冒发烧了，
孩子那头对吧，
你送到托儿所你就会知道了，
一定就是全班都必，
现在这个状态，
你一个人带着孩子啊，
这个挑战太大了，
就是我觉得我们我们分开的话是早晚的事情，
然后我是觉得现在是算是一个比较恰当的机会，
因为他父母这边是一定会要求我再生一个，
就是男孩子，
因为提过很多次了，
我跟你说啊，
如果你老公也接受这种貌合神离的状态，
也接受这种啊，
你过你的，
我过我的，
就是凑合的这种状态，
你还不如趁着婆婆能帮你带孩子，
你好好的攒点钱，
好好在工作上给自己夯实一下这种江湖地位，
工作上多有一些这种社会关系，
然后等孩子能上学了，
包括孩子。
比如说上小学了，
再说，
我一听到说你娘家也帮不上忙，
跟娘家也闹翻了，
你一个女人，
你又要工作，
又要租房子，
又要带孩子，
就算你买房子的话，
你又要工作，
又要装修，
又要带孩子，
真的是抵御风险的能力几乎为零啊，
万一你感冒了是吧，
谁帮你看孩子，
万一这个孩子在学校里面感冒了，
谁带他去医院，
你又要上班又要挣钱，
你又不是说铁饭碗，
你说你是个当老师的，
你铁饭碗你请假不怕，
你给人家打工，
你请假人家就把你给开了，
你到时候没有经济来源，
真的啊，
姐妹，
我不建议你这个阶段，
就算说你想好了，
你要跟他分开，
我不建议这个阶段分开，
你可能等，
比如说啊，
孩子读小学了是吧，
我孩子自己，
你要是说没时间接待人家，
自己光中关照都能走回家了，
人家自己关上门，
恨不得自己都能扔个面条了，
目前这个情况我其实也挺纠结的，
就是他这边比较善变，
主要是他这边比较善变，
我刚开始也跟他说的很明白，
我说这种这种情况如果能保持下去的话，
我也不会说要求你给我就是分什么东西也不会花你的钱，
我自己自己赚钱自己花也行，
我跟你说一旦是这样子的，
当你一旦心里不把他当老公看是吧，
我心里已经做好了，
我早晚有一天要离开你的这个状态，
第一我肯定要做老师嘛，
对不对。
第二，
我能躲着你我就躲着你吗？
能少见面跟我什么见面？
能不见面就不见面吗？
对不对？
第三，
我已经不把你当老公看了，
你还有什么情绪能够波动到我呢？
我还会因为你衣服归宿而生气吗？
我还会因为你跟别人聊我还发飙吗？
我还发狂吗？
我不，
我现在就是说找一个好的合作伙伴，
比如说婆婆是一个好的合作伙伴，
那婆婆就帮我带着孩子，
我踏踏实实挣钱，
踏实实攒钱。
是吧，
好的好的，
谢谢谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜，
好，
这个情况确实是你们大家但凡自己带过孩子的人都应该有体会，
对不对？
你不挣钱，
你带孩子都挺辛苦的，
你还别说又挣钱又带孩子，
所以其实人是这样子的，
一旦你不把她当老公看，
你就对他没有期待，
你不会期待他，
哎哟，
孩子过生日了，
他会不会关心一下？
你过生日了，
他会不会想着你，
是吧？
孩子生病了，
他是不是要陪着孩子去医院一起去你，
你不把他当老公看的时候，
你压根儿就不会有这些期待，
你就想着他，
只要不给我找事儿，
只要咱俩不打架就挺好，
你就把自己当成一个演员，
你现在就是忍辱负重，
忍辱负重就是为将来能够离开的时候很潇洒，
很从容，
离开了之后，
自己也能过得很好，
安排的井井有条，
你要一旦你的角色切换为一个演员，
我重生到这个阶段的话，
我就是要为自己活，
为我的孩子活，
我重生了之后，
我就不再纠结这个男的爱不爱我，
这个男的对吧，
对我还有没有感情，
就这男的，
他只要不作妖，
他不打我，
他只要说对孩子还有一点贡献，
对家庭还有一点贡献，
还有一点我，
对吧？
最后再提醒一点，
下一次他再让你去签什么字啊什么的啊，
你就找理由啊，
你去找理由你就不签呀，
或者说下次他再让你签字的时候，
你就说我们先去领个证啊。
我们先去领个证，
我们离婚不离家呀，
保证孩子万一你将来上黑名单了是吧，
或者是怎么怎么样了，
能够保证孩子有一个正常的家长啊，
说服他先领个证也是可以的，
但是我离婚不离家呀，
我还得靠着婆婆帮我带孩子呀，
我还得有地方住啊。